this show is presented by on it
the trick to what's happening now is
brought to you by helix sleep
go to helixsleep.com answer a few simple
questions and you can build a custom
mattress online that will cost you
hundreds instead of thousands and the
best part is when you go to
helixsleep.com joey right now you're
gonna get 50 off of your order that's
helixsleep.com
joey to get 50 off of your order
the show is also brought to you by blue
apron blue apron is the number one fresh
ingredient in recipe delivery service in
the country
check out this week's menu and get your
first three meals for free that's right
you get three meals for free with free
shipping by going to blueapron.com joey
my dad's signing up this week he he's
going to love it i love it go to
blueapron.com
joey to get your first three meals for
free with free shipping
oh [ __ ]
kick this mule lee
are you [ __ ] kidding me
this is as american as it gets the
church of what's happened now [ __ ] trump
[ __ ] hillary [ __ ] bernie sanders [ __ ]
them all here we go
are you kidding me
oh [ __ ]
wednesday the 22nd of february
the day the devil was buried at sea
let's do this [ __ ] kevin couch
here we go
i love this we're coming to your town
we'll help you party it down we're an
american man
we'll come into your town and we'll help
you party then who's better than that
nobody but they didn't say the magic
word nobody said nothing about sucking
my dick if they came to town magic work
you're not sticking my dick while you're
in my town why are you in my town you
know what i'm saying she can't cook i
don't want it yeah it should be like in
the uh package they give you at the
chamber of commerce it's like where you
are there's joey get to it what's
happening kevin what's going on hot
googly dude it's so good to see you it's
great to see you i'm so glad that i saw
you at the grocery store at six o'clock
in the morning
walking around stone like a [ __ ]
zombie yeah on a sunday before church i
looked at you i said jesus christ
what were you doing at the ralph's at
six in the morning i was going to church
i figured i'd stopping ralph's and
getting like a banana kill time for my
wife i don't know what the [ __ ] i was
doing in there i just thinking about him
the day before too and then i i go like
that dude looks like joey and i was like
oh wait i'm in los angeles that probably
is joey and then and then sure enough it
was true story i have found a little bag
of cocaine in line at that ralph's
right there in sherman oaks right there
at sherman oaks at uh cold water and uh
i was just like it was a tiny tiny bit
but i was just like
i thought no man i thought it was one of
those uh [ __ ]
it's los angeles i thought it was on
like a punk show or something so i did
the thing and i was like i gave it to
the the ralph's chick and
and she took it but there was cocaine
in the in the ralph's line that's not uh
that's not something that happens in
brookville and yeah graham you would
have taken it
i would yeah yeah i probably made some
money i paid for my groceries like
[ __ ] coke rock you put that in your
pocket
and just walk out of the rest i'll be
back
i'd pass that off instead of like a buck
i don't uh you don't dabble nah man i
don't mess with that you have a dabble
no not really never no
one time i uh the one time i ever did
cocaine it was when i first moved to los
angeles and i was at a party and oasis
was there doing cocaine and i thought
if you're ever gonna do it this is the
chat do it with oasis and so what lines
did you do
i mostly faked it i mostly went through
the other nostril i don't uh i don't
know good for you man yeah man that does
that stuff doesn't really yeah it
doesn't listen man not everybody is for
everybody yeah you know there's people
who do met i can't do [ __ ] met and
stay up for three days
yeah but some people do [ __ ] met you
know yeah i like do apples and i'm a boy
i'm like the most boring person that's
ever
you know been a friend of mine
from time
that's it and there's nothing wrong with
that it's like a cup of coffee here you
know for years i had this [ __ ] thing
i had to open or overcompensate with
coke because i didn't drink yeah so when
i went out you know after you do two or
three lines of coke you'll drink [ __ ]
horse piss
it doesn't matter as long as it's got
alcohol in it so jesus you know because
yeah you gotta trim that [ __ ] edge
off you gotta take the edge off you're
smoking cigarettes you're drinking
whiskey on the rocks
you know you're like forget the [ __ ]
back
you know if we get the ginger ale back
just give me the [ __ ] whiskey no ice
cubes i don't want ice cubes that's how
strong this blow is so i would drink but
i'm not a social drinker
yeah and i and i am be that i have
nothing like
i can't call lee and goliath what are
you doing right now no let's go get a
drink yeah we've never gotten a drink
we've never gone [ __ ] beer like i
don't i don't know i was saying that
about you today i was saying somebody
asked me they said well joey doesn't
drink and i said i don't think he does
drink but uh the cocaine thing i did
tell that story about the comedy store
where you had to jump in somebody's
truck
you had to jump in the back of
somebody's truck and you were doing it
off of some chick
that was the place in hollywood in the
freezer i think maybe oh the freezer
yeah yeah
ralphie may when i had a run
yeah yeah yeah and i had to run out of
uh this not the standard but the other
place
where dane cook became a king right
no across from uh
miyagi's
there used to be that big hot restaurant
there on tuesday nights i don't know and
that's where it was jay davies was the
host
and that's where that happened no i
haven't done blowing nine [ __ ] years
yeah it's gonna be [ __ ] november 7th
it'll be ten years you look great by the
way i did [ __ ] blow from the last
time yeah yeah because we used to go to
the gym too yeah yeah at the ymca yeah
the hollywood y and uh yeah you have
trimmed up how much weight have you lost
like 80 pounds like 100 15. yeah
looks good man you look you look healthy
crazy man fatherhood has been good to
you no i lost the weight before the
fatherhood oh did you i went down like
uh right before i knocked her up i went
to weight watchers for a year and i
went from 418 to [ __ ]
270. yeah
my head got too big and i was starting
to get dizzy and [ __ ] and [ __ ]
people weren't hiring me for roles
because i was going through these
auditions and my neck was really skinny
and like you ever see when somebody has
cancer or they just go into chemo yeah
yeah my neck looks all [ __ ] up so i
said [ __ ] this
i want to play 290. now i'm about like
297. as long as i'm not 300 pounds i'm
good yeah you know that's my that's the
thing i
stray away from over the holidays i went
up to like 303 but that's great that's a
holiday yeah it's a holiday four pounds
account you know i remember having my
holidays that's almost like losing
weight
i'm going to houston texas
for two weeks over the holidays and
coming back new year's day and being 28
pounds heavy
like you don't even fit in your [ __ ]
pants you don't think you're [ __ ]
quick too how long did it took you how
like a year to lose that 115 pounds and
you gained 28 in three weeks
two weeks two weeks but that soda is
that's yeah you know i don't even i
don't know when i drink soda anymore
like it's just wild yeah i fill this
thing up with water every day i take it
to jiu jitsu with me and until that
thing ain't [ __ ] done i don't drink
anything else yeah you know and i
[ __ ] hate it i'm not gonna lie to you
water out of a tin can like a soldier
yeah
i think that there was a point and and
you know maybe this would happen with
you too and it happened with me where
you just go okay i can wake up feeling
like [ __ ] every day now or i can you
know drink water stop drinking soda you
know live a little bit healthier as an
adult when did you guys start seeing a
noticeable difference like when did it
go from waking up feeling fine to oh
[ __ ] i feel like crap in the morning
i felt like crap in the morning until
nine years ago yeah that's about doing
blow i mean when did it start your diet
is terrible
listen when you go home yeah we mean you
go out and we have 22 [ __ ] drinks
and we smoke reefer and we borrow food
and we dehydrate and then we go out and
get bonnie's beanery or i'm just right
yeah right now
all of that yeah
and you go home
even if you sleep you don't sleep
because your stomach is digesting that
[ __ ] food
so you don't really get get into that
deep rim yeah you say you slept great
and you wake up and you feel tired
you still were moving you still were
doing stuff yeah man you know it's like
eating sugar before you go to bed yeah
you know like sometimes i go home
and i get stoned i leave here i go over
there and i [ __ ] eat yogurt raisins
my daughter's yogurt
now granted she has a little box i eat
like 30 of those boxes
my wife wakes up like what [ __ ]
happened last night when i wake up the
next morning i wake up feeling like dick
yeah you know those days yeah it's and i
told lee this that
your diet changes as you get older like
i have a friend that
cannot eat pizza no more and he is
losing it yeah italian kid like grew up
with lose we're losing his mind because
he can't have
his business his thing his whole thing
is a slice of pizza in the air totally
there's nothing like being from jersey
or new york or boston those places you
get used to the slice the slice holds
you over
you know the slice is six points
right a slice of pizza diet coke you
ain't killing nobody you know at two in
the afternoon and it holds especially a
good cheese slice too like a cheese
slice that's it just the cheese slices
six points yeah you know and it holds
you over
and i guess he's 50 and the cheese
[ __ ] his stomach up now yeah like and
you stop eating different things it's
not that i
that my willpower got any stronger no
it's that you know what
i know what it's like to get up in the
morning and smoke a marlboro red and a
can of coke yeah you have no idea you
wake up in the morning you smoke a
marlboro light and a can of coke
that's an instant dead sentence for the
day yeah like your day is done
that burst of sugar that early in the
morning i mean i would go from the bed
to the refrigerator and normal
i remember one time i was in uh this was
uh this is about five years ago uh i was
in a uh psychiatrist's office not not
for myself but for somebody else
no i've been known for myself i'm not
i'm not dissing that but it wasn't for
me this time and uh so this mom was just
her kid was hyperactive and she was
going okay we're gonna find a way to
calm you down and and it's nine o'clock
in the morning and the kid is you know
funyun snickers
coke and that that's the breakfast for
this kid and i'm going there's no secret
here to why this kid is like freaking
out in the morning
yeah and why she's at school and uh you
know mind is racing and all that stuff
like it's it's right there like i can
save you a whole lot of money and just
say hey you know
give the kids like a bagel and some tea
or something you know instead of the
instead of that [ __ ] [ __ ] cereal a
scrambled egg anything is better than
the [ __ ] snickers everybody yeah
anything better than a goddamn and i'll
tell you i never went that low yeah like
really no i never got that love to a
candy bar i always had to eat food yeah
but you see it all the time you see it
everywhere i like a candy bar at night
yeah you know you get back from the
comedy show you're at the hotel you're
hungry there's a [ __ ] almond joy for
four bucks
in the whole town right
give me the [ __ ] i'm enjoying four
bucks i'll shop with one and
we'll [ __ ] leave it out somewhere
along the goddamn line you know
but no you just don't
it's tough now like i
when i was working full-time and i see
like if you go to a 7-eleven at like
five or six in the morning they're
packed with like people working in
construction and they're getting donuts
and coffees and when i would work in
santa monica like and i lived up here
i i would have it timed out so i would
wake up and shower and get in the car i
didn't want to make breakfast it took an
hour and a half to get there anyways
and they have they have like granola
bars or something in the office i'll eat
that and and free soda so that's what i
did for years
and this don't get me wrong guys
my mother had a bar
so when the soda order would come from
the bar half of it would go to the house
she just built the bar you know i'm
saying like bread
my refrigerator this is no lie growing
up my refrigerator top shelf was coke
second shelf was seven up and i mean oh
yeah no
that's the way i grew up the third shelf
was mateba yeah cuban
herb soda and then the fourth shop was
way
matatoyo put a pound on you every time
you drink that [ __ ]
all right never mind if you put the
[ __ ] condensed milk i was going to
say what's wrong with the cubans do
whatever and all that [ __ ] you know
there was four things in my house my
stepdad used to go crazy
he used to go i come home at five and
there's
half a cans they have coke everywhere i
would drink [ __ ] coke all day i
didn't know what water was i [ __ ]
hated water yeah hated it
and i drank cokes till
2009.
yeah my first kidney stone got me away
from that because i was drinking 2009. i
was drinking diet 7up
because uh i'm an idiot and i'm looking
at it going it's clear
it's got to be at least a little bit
better right it tastes like fruit
a little bit
and then i'm just drinking i'm pounding
those things and i got a kidney stone
and i was like okay that's uh that's the
end of my career with soda i have that's
my worst nightmare i literally i bought
a thing on amazon for like kidney health
because i drank so much soda i've cut
way down i still drink a little bit i
need to cut to zero
but
like that's my worst nightmare like what
happened to matt matrianica a week or so
ago
all right i can't what happened to him
he had a kidney stone that's why you
couldn't fight fedor
and what do they what do you get those
from from it's uh uh it's not from a lot
of things but soda i think red meat like
isn't there there's something that's
like it just calcified things in your
kidney and the only way to get it out is
either like
surgery or just has to like force its
way through your penis hole and it just
apparently kills i went before they
forced away
so yeah that it was not it was not
really no good yeah through your pee
hole yeah and how how long is the
painful uh
man i mean i can tell you it seemed like
two weeks but it's probably like four
days oh you know it's like i mean it
hurt
hurt a while
yeah yeah i'm gonna start drinking
something but i i drink the [ __ ]
whatever juice from my stomach i really
take care of my stomach i bought that
stuff for gut rot
and i drank the water with it the toxic
sludge
yeah there's a radio commercials where
they're like you may not be fat you
might be bloated yeah like that's better
news yeah
thinking about going to that place and
sticking the tube up my ass and washing
it out with
tea or whatever they colonics whatever
oh i thought you're just saying like no
no i'm really something about some dude
at the gym is doing that for free i
joined jiu jitsu three years ago and i
discovered that i had this really weird
anxiety on my back
just mind-boggling that's why i was
telling you about stress and exactly
yeah yeah yeah i'm not a big anxiety guy
till about uh i think once i got off the
blow when the anxiety started appearing
i didn't know what it really was
but when i went to jiu jitsu it was so
bad
and i just you know tried to fight
through it but i'm not really growing um
so last week i finally went to
got hypnotized oh not that guy give it a
shot
it was what it was i paid for five
sessions
i'm gonna go in there with an open mind
you know that's the only way you go into
things like that and uh
i'm gonna go for [ __ ] broke and see
what happens i went to today
i didn't have any panic attacks but you
made a point see a kid said to me goes
get some asthma stuff
and spray your lungs i gotta tell you
something every time i sprayed my lungs
as my [ __ ] i would go to jiu jitsu and
die yeah and go what the [ __ ] this is
i'm dying does it make your head crazy
because that's that's what it was doing
to me like i had uh because uh just to
so everybody has a little background i
had some anxiety problems when when you
and i knew each other and far before
that took a lot of medication for it but
it ended up being a misdiagnosis and i
had been taking this medication for
years and years this affects are for
panic attacks and uh then it wasn't
panic attacks it was just a
bad reaction from a chemical that was in
my asthma inhalers
so um you know we were talking about
changing our diet so when i i cut milk
out of my diet because i i went vegan
for a woman how you do so when you go
vegan you take milk up yeah milk is gone
what else is good milk meat um
honey fish yeah anything with a face
anything from a face kind of thing yeah
and uh are you eating a [ __ ] day
vegetables man and plus i'm in uh i'm in
rural indiana at this point so i got to
go to the farmer's market to get
vegetables and a lot of potatoes um no
when you're a vegan what do you use for
protein
uh spinach um i eat a lot of quinoa i
eat a lot of tofu
um
and then i also do a uh a whole
shake thing that's like 35 grams of
protein every day it's water you make it
with water no i make it with like jude
mango usually mango puree or uh i make a
green one so so it's more of a health
thing for me you know but then it's
taking you off the anxiety medication
absolutely i took that [ __ ] from the
time i was like probably 20 until what
like uh
i don't know man 35
and uh
you know it was just
you know after a while it just made my
my whole head numb because the answer to
it like it was like i'm still having
these problems and the answer was always
take more effects and take more effects
until i finally just got to a point
where i'm like you know i'm not laughing
anymore you know and i'm i'm not crying
at things that are really sad you know
my grandpa was dying and i didn't feel
anything you know at the time and
um
so that's when i just kind of cut it out
all together um but then
going back to the the cutting out the
milk the milk was giving me asthma
problems the asthma inhaler was giving
me these
you know
psychotic uh
you know sort of panic attacks and then
so when i cut out milk i cut out the
asthma some
and now you have nothing nothing to talk
i have not taken a hit off of my uh
i take that back i've taken one hit off
of an asthma inhaler since 2009
and uh
i you know no no not one panic attack so
so
dairy was making you have asthma or you
have like a little bit of asthma and
dairy makes it worse uh i don't really
know it's just dairy i think was given
me it builds up the mucus in your lungs
you know
and uh and i'm a farm boy and so
milk was a cornerstone of my diet you
know i drink milk with everything you
know i drink milk you know two glasses
for dinner you know glass for breakfast
and
you know throughout the day so what
saves me is i don't like milk yeah i
don't like the smell of milk i'll have a
milkshake though like a [ __ ]
yeah
piece of ice cream and some [ __ ]
stevia and that's a great shake uncle
joey i'm good i like it thin
and i'll make it with two percent uh
milk you know just to hold me over or
something like that but i've never been
a big milk guy let me ask you something
my ears now you're from ohio uh indiana
but yeah like right in that corner where
uh indiana ohio and kentucky meet
where'd you go to college manchester
college which is now manchester
university and you had you got a degree
in radio there uh yeah broadcasting well
yeah communication studies yeah and when
we met you were a national lampoon right
on uh sunset next to that [ __ ] bar i
can't believe you don't know
was it that irish bar nah the one that's
like a
structure now like an engineering it's
empty yeah completely empty now nobody's
even in there but i don't remember that
bar
data
you know when we started talking a few
months ago
i started thinking about you know all
the that was the beginning of my
podcasting career
without knowing right you were letting
me do whatever the [ __ ] i wanted to do
right we were even doing the martial
arts minute and we review chinese movies
joey karate joey karate we do uh
uh what's that sonny chiba sonny chiba
yeah dude
yeah yeah yeah
this was my education and radio because
yeah you learned to do radio on the road
with goofy people and they ham it up and
who the [ __ ] knows but
this was like kevin couch teaching me
all this [ __ ] like this is what you do
this like it was just you and me and we
were there every week i know tripoli
would go in there sam tripoli was there
she would go into the christian champs
[Music]
josh wolfe josh wolfe would go in there
i mean this is joe bartnick was the
sports guy joe martin was an excellent i
think joe was actually working in radio
in los angeles right now yeah
so this is 10 years ago
yeah 10 years ago 2007. yeah that's
right
jesus says about 2005 to 12 2004 2008 i
think was with lampoon
on xm okay yeah we're on xm and then we
i think we had some terrestrial
affiliates too
um but you know what like every there
was so much over there that was a lie
like i don't know what was true you know
like you tell the story and you always
have to put an asterisk by every story
it's like uh they said we had 30
affiliates but you know i never saw
evidence of that i never went to miami
to listen to it you know so i don't know
if it actually actually was there they
moved us from one office
to a smaller office yeah remember we're
on that floor with jamie foxx that's
like it was just our office and then
jamie foxx's production company that was
the first studio
and then um that was over on the other
the the west side of uh sunset over by
the hamburger hamlet and then we moved
into the actual national lampoon
building building um which was across
from you know more across from like the
laugh factory
um
yeah no no no it was down more by that
mexican restaurant on the corner
remember we used to [ __ ] window pinching
yeah yeah yeah well what was right
across from uh chateau martin chapter
one chat martial
when ping che first opened yeah we would
sit in the window and go like when i
leave here i'm gonna go to pin chain
drop 40 on mexican food it was good
mexican good [ __ ] mexican that was
awesome
yeah last time i went with lee i didn't
go for like five years
and i walked in there with me not
knowing anything i could only just get
three tacos i got three tacos it's like
11 30 at night you know yeah
and the guy looked at me goes well
you're not going to get those potato
things remember they used to make those
potatoes oh yeah yeah yeah those things
put 20 [ __ ] pounds on you like uh
yeah one of the things you like
no flouters okay yeah
that was that place there across from
chateau ma month i think that was a uh
one of those naked sushi places before
it was pinched no or is that still there
no no no okay
the naked sushi place was what the naked
sushi place is
naked women yeah the [ __ ] that
restaurant
has had the kiss of death in it since i
got here since 1997 when i signed with
media artist agency that's where the
agent took me to lunch breakfast
and it closed a week after that
then it became a lunch spot then it
became then it became a naked sushi spot
where a lady lays on the table they put
sushi on her and you [ __ ] eat the
sushi off of them does everything look
like a naked lady i don't know how it
was yeah it was embarrassing to go in
there yeah well it was
people like me don't go in there because
you i i could never in a million years
afford that because something tells me
that's uh 200
yeah yeah i mean ridiculous naked ladies
not just going to come sit there all
[ __ ] night with you no no um but uh
yeah it was a it was a lady per table
jesus have you seen that famous prayer
that i don't know if it's famous that
picture of eddie murphy eating like a
steak and french fries off of a naked
woman in like new york
unlike the roof of his building
that's crazy i can't imagine eating off
of a naked lady
that's a [ __ ] man but i didn't know
you know or
you know i guess if i was there somebody
was feeding and they said eat the
[ __ ]
shrimp cocktail off my [ __ ] i mean
i guess i'm leaving the shrimp cocktail
yeah we'll need the tartar sauce yeah i
think they cover them with kind of i
think there was like a kelp
right she had something to cover or
something wasn't like when you got there
you're like this is a beat yeah there's
a she ain't [ __ ] naked she got
lettuce on it yeah it's just a [ __ ] just
a bikini i wanted to see a naked woman
from my 200. oh and i get some chick
covered with lettuce and [ __ ] plus the
sushi i mean it's hot i don't care if
it's off a woman or not it has to be
good for two hundred dollars yeah how
good can that you know
those places are just a place you walk
in there and go i went to that place
yeah nights ago yeah like i was the
sushi would you go back
you know
all right
i'll go to sushis and mine and take my
[ __ ] chances and [ __ ] what was your
first radio job after
manchester you stayed in indiana what
the [ __ ] made you come out here um my
first job was at uh radio station called
97x woxy in cincinnati you ever seen the
movie rain man yeah where he's like 97x
bam the future of rock and roll that was
my that was my first station i did
mornings there
um
and i was a music director for a little
bit and uh that was the first place i
ever got fired so yeah it was
um but that was the best radio station
um that was the one i grew up listening
to and um i was a senior in in college
when i got hired there initially
for uh for like weekend work so i took
my last year at miami of ohio
so
but
unless you end up with [ __ ]
los angeles no that
that national lampoon
uh how did i end up at national lampoon
i was working at k earth in los angeles
i'd come into you've always been a
character i've always i have always how
many years all together i have been a
part of the key earth morning show caret
101 in los angeles um give it a plug
there
since uh 2003
in some capacity like i came in with the
hollywood hamilton show then i worked
with the gary bryan show for a little
bit and then i went to lampoon and i
became like a part-time employee of k
earth right because you would you
couldn't work a couple days a week no
you you know was that something you did
something that there was one day a week
you wouldn't be there right something
crazy right i remember that and then
with gary bryan uh you know
we all work for a production company
called radio genius so we all do that
together which is uh stuff that you know
the work that goes towards the show too
so yeah so since 2003
you know give or take a little bit there
i worked at seacrest there for four
months there was like a four month
window there where i was over at that
show um
but yeah i know k earth is you know i've
been i've been there for a long time can
you believe that these comics you were
working with 10 years ago are doing what
they're doing today i'm so proud of some
of these guys man
[Music]
that was his first radio interview when
burke chrysler made fun of him because
his voice was cracking and uh and and i
always tell tom and and i'm sure he gets
annoyed as hell with this but uh you
know we were born in the same hospital
so that's uh
mercy hospital hamilton ohio but um
yeah so i've always sort of like uh
you know bert's been or not burt um
um tom has been somebody that you know
i'm always
you know i've always been cheering for
and christine absolutely i've actually
seen christina a couple times when she
went out to the midwest
you know i saw her show sorry shafir
when he came out
um matt iceman dude [ __ ] look at that
guy just one celebrity apprentice and
uh host an american ninja warrior and uh
you know and and you know i'm super
happy for that dude because he used to
come on my show just you know you shoot
him a facebook message and he'd be there
in an hour you know and then and now
he's um you know that's celebrity
apprentice thing he's like oh hell yeah
man good for him
but um
who about josh wolfe got a tv show and
um that's [ __ ] crazy who else is on
the on the uh matt walker yeah do you
know matt walker no um
he uh he just is up for a radio show too
he used to come in with um
mike moratori and they did a they did a
little segment where the [ __ ] is mike
moratory um i saw him at the ice house
last year i think um he's around he's
around two years three years i really
disappeared i'd see him at the ice house
and then
over again i think he's around i see him
doing shows i see his notices and stuff
but
no he was teaching geno karate
yeah yeah yeah no i didn't you know
what's [ __ ] crazy that just came back
to me okay
so i was promoting something
around the holidays
i can't remember what the [ __ ] it was
and i went to see you at the place by
hamburger hamlet
okay it was real cool when you said to
me if you want to do anything yeah
call me yeah i thought about it over the
holidays and i called you but then you
moved
all right you guys went over to the
other side there you go yeah okay so i
met you when you were still a hamburger
hamlet yeah in that thing in there and
then that was the first time i only went
to that studio
one time yeah
that was a cool studio is that me man
i'm sorry that's like totally
unprofessional
good together jordan lee says great job
i'm watching thanks jordan thanks jordan
i appreciate it
jordan um yeah i know the uh uh
that hamburger hamlet place that studio
was cool like we had a um
you know a lot more room you know so we
could bring more comics in
um but the uh you know when we moved
over to that net other studio that was
you know it was a tiny it was kind of a
tight field
that was a super tight fit it was you
guys on the first floor i think and then
jay shack that had an office upstairs
with the other dude that was like the
the national like the national lampoon
radio guy the radio guys were down there
uh we had two rooms and then upstairs
was like the
lampoon lampoon guys the guys that did
the the movie stuff yeah
the whole time i've been thinking about
it i'm like jesus christ
i brought jodie ferdigan one morning all
right yeah i i helped out with that they
did a queens of tarts
tour
and uh
i helped get some like radio interviews
for him for that with uh lang parker
blaine parker yeah you still see lange
though i talked to her a lot she's a
good lady yeah she's awesome man she's
one of my favorite people for sure um
you know
i've known jodie furtick since 1997 and
jody ferdig is uh
so on the top side
to
she's grown uh you know as a comedian
she was she just
stalled that one
part because of the alcohol you know and
over the years she's tried to make
comebacks and whatnot and uh
like i said i used to work with jody a
lot but
it got to the point where it was uh it
got crazy you know yeah and i wasn't mad
at her she's just a crazy person she
tries to drink and jump up and down and
dance
so i get this call one day from jody and
she's telling me she's doing a tour with
lang and some other sweet girl
and they're doing vegas and something
else and you know i was like good luck
man you know
and i mean they weren't on the road a
[ __ ] week yeah and people calling me
going i bumped into your girl in vegas
[ __ ] hammond yeah i just
and i know you know yeah i'm not any
sort of my business you know but i would
get calls from time to time from vegas
right
and finally the tour ends and uh
i i'm not thinking about it you know i
got other things on my mind i'm not
thinking about three girls on a tour but
when i'm at the improv when i walk out
there's lane parker with this face like
somebody hit her in the head with a
stick
and she's like you know i i know she's
your friend but i gotta get rid of
religion
get rid of her yeah i don't give a [ __ ]
right you know but lange was like
i felt really bad for her because yeah
well that's how she is she's a huge
hearted person man she's a country chick
too yeah yeah from that world yeah
like i understood jody because i'm from
that world i'm a piece of [ __ ]
getting high and [ __ ] but when lane came
up to me she's like joey she got to a
fight with a hooker in the lounge
you know i could see joanie fighting
with her
in the [ __ ] lounge okay you know so i
was like
and i thought lang thought that
she was i don't know lang thought that i
would be mad no not at all yeah when it
comes to comedy or somebody's job
i'm a firm believer anybody [ __ ] you
your job you gotta get rid of them right
everybody [ __ ] at your job you gotta
get rid of them like i just don't like
it i don't [ __ ] with nobody's job that's
how you feed your goddamn family you
know
but she used to go on the road with
ralphie and have drama you know ralphie
took her on the river one time
and they went to uh columbus not
columbus
the other big one a guy named not stroop
but there was a comedy club owner who
left recently and he's running the ships
now he took a big big big job with ships
but he was big in the funny bone chain
so ralphie's stuck so he goes who should
i take
you know like oh we'll call jody
so they get there the first thing
ralphie looks at joey and says
don't say nothing to that guy about him
being short
johnny goes to the bar does it 30
minutes gets off does three shots of
jaeger oh man six beers
and calls him a [ __ ] [ __ ] i mean
you know that's the type of person jody
is and she thought she was being funny
and i got it you know i'd be laughing
too
but
when you're in that ralphie may category
yeah yeah chances like that right yeah
there's a time to [ __ ] around not time
not to [ __ ] around
but until this day i always think about
lang and just shake my head because
nobody can handle her yeah like nobody
can be around them more than two nights
after two nights they're like no more
like seriously and lang is so nice yeah
you know she's such a nice person
there's no way that she can be you know
she's not gonna be a [ __ ] unless she
you know i've never i mean i can't even
say if she's gonna be i've never seen
her be a [ __ ] what's your problem over
there [ __ ] oh i have no problem it's uh
it's i can't imagine it just makes me it
makes me
like uncomfortable thinking about like
just making trouble for someone just for
no real like no reason like just
especially after i told you like listen
man be cool
yeah when i pull you yeah it'll be cool
like i expect that that's how
professionals yeah yeah that's how we do
it listen i expect everybody to be cool
right you know i'm like i'm fine you
come home and you go i'm gonna go out
with you and do comedy i know you're
gonna be cool yeah if i come out and and
you're punching somebody because they
grabbed your dick i'm not going to be
mad at you yeah but if i heard that you
threw a drink at somebody and called him
a contour hey i gotta be mad yeah you're
[ __ ] my [ __ ] up yeah i'm saying
you're [ __ ] my [ __ ] up
a lot of people don't understand that
he's like i'm doing you a favor chill
chill the [ __ ] out a lot of people
understand that that's the weird thing
when it comes to comedy people think
like in the green room there's a party
there's no [ __ ] party i'm watching
espn
i'm sitting back here drinking water
watching espn can't wait for the [ __ ]
boat shows to be over there's no [ __ ]
party
i i couldn't imagine
still getting high like i was on the
road
no like i can't imagine no i can't
imagine
if i was still doing those drugs but
then you came to that point where it's
like okay i'm gonna i'm gonna be this
guy now or i've gotta be this guy right
like that that's how i was i was like
okay i can be the party fun guy for the
rest of my life where i can get my [ __ ]
together and like
first of all i never wanted to be the
party funny i didn't give a [ __ ] about
parties but you know what i'm telling
you you know what as long as i had my
grandma blow yeah that's all i gave a
[ __ ] life i swallowed i count that
thought that as a party you know it's
funny how a lot of guy like i i became
uh
anti-social yeah you know i was really
anti-social i was just gonna grab a coke
and go
if by chance i got horned up
if she knew the rules
because everybody got to know the rules
before you come over here
the rules are i got a g bow and a half
you come over here somebody's gonna get
naked the same free the same gratis i
just imagine like a little sign before
you get onto like a roller coaster like
you have to be 48 inches tall
you have to
i was so [ __ ] nuts so i can't even
like you don't really hear about
comedians being crazy no more you don't
you don't know it's changing you don't
hear it about written radio people
either you know like no no no no no when
you get a bunch of radio people into
these groups you know uh because there's
a you know i've been around long enough
to where i know some of the older guys
have been around for a while and they
tell these stories and you're just like
man that doesn't that doesn't happen at
all you know when i started in the like
in the 90s it kind of ended i would say
around like 98 99 you know and then and
just you don't have those wild crazy
huge personalities anymore
you know well i'll tell you i think i
when mitch hedberg died yeah
it shocked people so much you know
and i love mitch i'm not saying nothing
bad about him i'm just saying what
everybody knows you know
there was a couple comics out there
including myself
at that time that we were out there
doing blowing [ __ ]
you don't hear about it no more
you know you'd hear something once a
month about
this guy or that guy or me you know he
had that
uh for anxiety
i have to take
a point five like my doctor waxler yeah
gives me like a 0.5
i think it's his addicts
like tomorrow morning at full when i get
up
just the fact that i gotta leave my
family and [ __ ] i get anxiety mm-hmm i'm
one of those [ __ ] in the ride i'll
pop a a 0.5 don't put you to sleep it
don't make you crash your car yeah
don't do nothing
but a friend of mine yeah they said i
got a couple of v's for you
and he laid a couple visas on me and i
took him home and i haven't
been able to pick one up yeah because
the last time i ate
milligame valium like 30 of them
in [ __ ] three days
you know yeah last time i had a violin i
ate 30 [ __ ] valiums 10 milligram
valiums in three [ __ ] days
i was falling asleep on the stage
on the floor yeah josh wolf reminds me
about that
whenever he tells me these stories might
like my [ __ ] heart stops yeah like i
still remember it was they were in a
brown bag
like they didn't give them to me the
pill container and i was just shoving my
hand on the back and i remember
shoving my hand in that bag
and jiggling the bag around and going oh
[ __ ]
there's no more valiums
like i ate 30 10 milligram [ __ ]
valiums
i i don't know i know you said that you
don't really hear people going crazy
anymore but at least for me the way i
grew up
if i had if i was still in boston right
now the most i'd probably would have
done would be weed
and and just hearing like
you ari and you doing acid going to pink
floyd and trying to go to pink floyd and
then mushrooms and all that like for me
like for me edibles are kind of crazy
like like
my nature now they're not now they're
now it's not a day if i don't have an
edible but
it's crazy
it's just crazy like to me that's crazy
to me that's
partying
like just
the fact that people do dr uh pills out
here
not for
like
prescribed reasons like i would have
never thought to take
like a valium or like i was talking with
uh
danny brown about how when the first
time i got uh bronchitis out here they
gave me coding and someone asked to buy
it if i didn't finish it and i was like
why would he want to buy this oh i don't
get that and that doesn't happen where
you're from maybe you did and i'm just
oh man biggest nerd in the world uh like
when i when i moved back to this small
town where i'm from man that uh this is
like indiana
uh
like heroin is a real problem real
problem
and methamphetamine oh my god
in mass right now it's crazy they said
heroin is huge and that's maybe that's a
weird thing is i left my hometown at 18
and never would never went back right
and i i was in college from i was in
boston from 19 to 21
but i was
working and
kind of really subdued i didn't do
anything crazier than drink
so it's uh i i wonder if i went back now
and live there now it might be maybe
it's the same everywhere but yeah i was
so naive as a kid well this is uh
you know i'm kind of close to where uh
dayton is you know where they keep doing
all these stories on you know the heroin
epidemic and it seems a center there in
dayton ohio and um but yeah i mean there
was like uh the the town north of us he
had like 11 overdoses in a weekend you
know i mean the los angeles doesn't have
that in a week you know and it was just
uh
um
but going back to your prescription drug
things like anything with opioids man
that is like a hot ticket you know i
mean people there was a
to give you another
did you like fargo the series when that
came out no you never watched it because
i i loved fargo because it was like um
you know being in one of these little
small towns is sort of off the radar
these crazy things happen there like uh
this dude like shot five people and
killed them over pills
and it was just uh i mean and it was you
know barely a you know a two-day thing
on the news but i mean that really
happened that was scary as [ __ ]
and um you know so when i moved back i
got this apartment
um
like right there on main street in my of
my hometown and it's like 16 foot
ceilings you know it was like a an old
building i think it's built in like 1890
or something you know just huge windows
it was just a cool place to live like
like a half gymnasium inside
and um
like more than
i don't want to say it happened once a
month but it was you know around once
every two months somebody would knock
like some junkie chick would knock on
that i don't know who lived there before
i did but the police had come a couple
times looking for somebody too
but uh like junkie chicks would just
bang on my window you know and then when
i would come to the door they'd be like
oh you know [ __ ] sorry and take off
running but uh you know that doesn't
that doesn't happen to me in los angeles
you know what i mean um but yeah i can
totally see somebody offering you that
uh for coding that's that's a hot ticket
yeah pills have been a problem for years
not as bad
as the problem now you know a couple
years ago with the oxycontin
yeah that's that's huge yeah florida
with the pain relief centers and all and
i was telling my wife the other day
a comedian once gave me like a [ __ ]
eighth
of an oxycodone
and like let me go home and pop this
thing i mean it was nothing it was
nothing it was a little piece and i just
popped it
and within 30 minutes i had to go lay
down my blood pressure dropped i'm like
i don't know how the [ __ ] people eat
this [ __ ] man like how the [ __ ] people
eat this [ __ ] i don't i'm sort of one of
those people now that i'm paranoid
against all pills you know you know how
like people are getting there's that
fringe i'm starting to join that fringe
of like if it's in pill form man i don't
want to take it you know i'll just i'll
find another way i'll take the pain or
something way before i knew joey and
it's still to this day scares me i will
not take a pill that's not prescribed to
me because my mom told me that that's
how bruce lee died is that he took a
pill
that wasn't prescribed for him and he
died it was like the wrong
whatever and that that freaked me out so
i don't i don't take
i guess maybe i'm taking like some
codeine and mushrooms and crazy stuff
but i don't
prescriptions freak me out yeah i'm like
that's not good i'm gonna be like bruce
lee i'll die
you're gonna [ __ ] die [ __ ] it be fine
when i was it's good to have at least
one com one thing in common with bruce
lee though right you know like i've got
as it is now i have nothing in common
with that dude
it's uh when i was about 17 there was a
kid
in north bergen that his mother had
cancer
and the mother knew she was going to die
so she would take the pain relief
medication and sell it
at top dollar because
you know the tuminols they were
quaaludes
but she used to have [ __ ] like
this pill that was like an f66
that's what it sounded f76 and people
knew like it was like the f66 express
and every pill was like 20 bucks in 1982
like yeah 20 dollars yeah i did 25 was a
[ __ ] quarter gram right now so you're
like [ __ ] it but i remember taking an
m66 one time splitting it with a friend
of mine his name was kishka we used to
call them those that they were tuminols
i used to just call him to me for sure
because at that point that's all he ever
ate the kid to me come on don't call me
two me people don't call that so we
split one
and it was like lee and me like the way
lee is weighing a thousand milligrams
and he's like
i was [ __ ] up and this kid was like
talking on the phone and making collages
and [ __ ] and i'm [ __ ] lit this [ __ ]
but i had eaten all those
and i figured if i didn't die from the
f-66 and a couple of the [ __ ]
quaaludes
one night i almost died guys
i was about 17 and i went to a party on
64th street field
with with to do lucci it was his
birthday his birthday is when my
birthday is
and lucci always had parties before
concerts
if there was a concert at the garden go
by lucci's at six o'clock they were
already lit
20 gorillas lit
so one night he was just having a party
but i took coke with me when they had
the spoons
on top of the bottle you ever see that
no they used to have little bottles and
a little chain with a spoon so you could
take the lid off and put the spoon
and i would put the
the coke in my top pocket and i remember
i took quaaludes with me and it was like
six o'clock at night and i popped two of
these gorilla biscuits and the problem
was in those days that
like i said a thousand times sometimes
the chemist had a table that was crooked
so all the [ __ ] quaalude juice would
go to the last two rows of quaalude all
the other quaaludes are like duds but
the last two rolls they could kill you
i must have popped two of those oh my
god
they woke me up at like three in the
morning i was out for like seven hours
out drooling
puking pissing [ __ ]
yes you know foaming the whole [ __ ]
deal how did they justify making a coke
a holder with a a spoon attached with a
chain like that seems like
like that seems cool like where would
you even get that that's like shot yeah
it's like all that [ __ ] that they used
to remember
the little glass roses they still sell
those in gas stations over there yeah
how [ __ ] crazy is yeah i did not know
that until about 10 years ago really
yeah like somebody goes no let's just go
buy one of those like what do you mean a
roll you're gonna buy rows got this and
i looked and i go you [ __ ] yeah
because you never knew that those roses
are cracked pipes i never [ __ ] knew
that yeah like every gas station has
them what do you think is just like uh
you know like what ethnicity gives away
these glass roses i must know their
culture that's how [ __ ] i was yeah i
didn't [ __ ] know but i was never
really scared of
there was only one drug i was scared of
and that was heroin when i did i wasn't
cocaine
there were some nights my heart wouldn't
stop beating
yeah
i thought it like a vein got loose in
there some nights it was [ __ ] quick
you're laying in bed with your wife or
girlfriend and the whole bed is shaking
from your heart
your heart is [ __ ]
people next to you wake up and go are
you okay and now let me ask you this
what's what's the uh
not to sound naive or anything but
what's the appeal after that happens one
time
who the [ __ ] knows
you know who the [ __ ] knows what's the
appeal of
going to the store after some guy comes
on on tv with a [ __ ] curtain on his
[ __ ] throat
with a voice box and goes i got that
from smoking cigarettes why would you go
down there yeah you know why would you
go to mcdonald's after you watch a
600-pound man in [ __ ] houston texas
walking around and there's mcdonald's
you know saying like why do we do half
the [ __ ] we do we know cigarettes are
bad for us we know caffeine is bad for
us now the last year or two or three
they're telling you how bad sugar is for
you certainly he's on these [ __ ]
sugar diets before you know we can't eat
dick
rice is bad for your bread is bad for
your soda's bad for you dude the trader
joe's told me oatmeal was bad for me
why what was the reason i don't know i i
kind of walked away i don't stick it
around for those conversations anymore
you know like how uh
i don't know how old you are but you
know how like those conversations like
somebody would come up to you and you'd
be like how do i get out of this
now i just get out of it and it's
awesome and i don't know why it took me
so long i'm still not getting out of it
yeah i try to be polite if i'm the
russian [ __ ] i i gotta make a move yeah
if if i could be polite i'm always
trying to be but how many conversations
did you have where somebody's just like
you're just like huh and you're like oh
my god and now it's just like all right
i gotta go and it's like i don't know
why it was so hard for all those years
to just go
all right i'm i'm out i'm done with this
one
a couple weeks ago i had a tape
something for animal planet
and
it was a long [ __ ] day you know we
started like it's nine and we had to go
downtown and to the west side and then
back to my house and we had to do this
all by five by the time the baby got
back
then we took like a two hour breath and
i had to go to flappers
they wanted me to do 10 minutes on cats
i had like four minutes on cats yeah and
i just wrote a couple of dumb [ __ ] just
so all i needed was ten seconds yeah
i go down there and i'm sitting there
and it's the gang show
oh yeah they're doing the gunk show
nbc's bringing it back abc
i'm like no they're not they had the
judges and [ __ ]
and they had like 40 people in the
audience you know and
there were people down there and i
noticed the comic was there that there's
a character around town yeah
i i don't know about that [ __ ] he comes
over oh what are you doing here i got to
do a 10-minute spot brother you know i
go you know there's just comics
who want to know what the [ __ ] you're
doing they just can't take hello for uh
what's up man you're good you're good
you're good man yeah i see you yeah they
see you talking to somebody they know
that person they want to come over and
mingle and be cute yeah you know so this
guy is one of those guys he comes over
now you know me bro i got no hatred for
somebody like that what are you gonna do
he comes over hi how are you good to see
you man and who are you oh how
interesting are you guys shooting a show
you know all that [ __ ] yeah yeah
meanwhile he's like going in his pocket
for a business card he's got a resume in
his back pocket you know the whole
[ __ ] deal
nice guy i've known this kid for like 15
16 years since he was a kid doing comedy
in florida
you may as well just name him now
over here
he's like so what are you doing and he's
asking me all these questions you know
i'm [ __ ] tired
all i want to do is do these [ __ ] 10
minutes and go home and now i got these
people from the gang show asking me do
you want to retape your set do you mind
if we put your ascent on my listen i
don't want to be on the [ __ ] gunk
show yeah all right i'm trying to be as
nice as i [ __ ] can okay yeah
and they kept coming over yeah the gun
show's going to be a great opportunity
for you listen i'm not ganging
so forget about the [ __ ] gun show
okay so already i'm starting to get
irritated like with the dog show people
now i got this comedian
asking me creepy questions
he's you know i got the [ __ ] gun show
people on the right side yeah and i got
this comedian on the left side and he's
asking me questions and i love him
dearly yeah but he doesn't look at me
he's not looking at my face knowing that
you know what let me take a hike
like there's some people and if i look
at you i know it means let me take a
[ __ ] hike not him yeah he's talking
talking talking talking
finally i go dog
you got to take you got to go show call
of the treat you got to go for a walk
okay
he leaves i go on stage i get off stage
these people from
new way
are uh are uh
these people from new wave are we going
to address that
these people from new wave are talking
to me right
these people from new way for talking to
me and the next thing you know
guess who comes up to me
the [ __ ] comedian yeah guess what he
says to me hey man i got some notes on
your set there he goes and he looks at
me and finally he goes do you want him
and by that point he looks like he goes
he looks at me he goes i can tell by
looking on your face you really don't
want him dude not really take a [ __ ]
night oh my god that night i went home
and i felt bad you know because i know
him a long time and it's like
when you see a comedian and he's with
people
that you don't know just say hello and
keep [ __ ] walking yeah i would never
get involved in some that's amateur
that's business 101 you know at the
comedy store there were comics that
would go up there at 8 30 and look at
the list
to see who had a showcase
like who had a star next to their name
and then they would tag on to you when
you walk in who you showcasing for apa
really yeah where are they right there
oh hey how are you like jesus christ
how [ __ ] creepy are you
like there's people who live for that
[ __ ] i'm not saying that this comedian
was creepy like that but he was creepy
like that
right right now if i hadn't worked all
day i would have got up and broke it
down from yeah i just was in the mood
i'm just living off sign language here
look at my body moving my face
do i look like i'm gonna have a [ __ ]
conversation i want to smoke a joint i
just want to get the [ __ ] out of here
yeah is that different with radio though
could like can you say oh oh the station
books the gas or the state like or or do
you still get hit up constantly
i mean and i'm not trying to heavy bad
talk anyone but just like how does it
work for radio like with that booking
and having people hit you up and
um
i'm not i'm not sure that i understand
the question like just like like like
it's kind of interesting radio and
podcasting are very similar but you you
work for the station right so do you get
hit up to be a guest on your show and
can you say oh
no i'll the station book say yes i don't
i can't do it i'm like
that we
uh brandon castillo and i booked the
guests um we usually you know there's
services too for for radio people you
know we're cbs rate well not i guess
we're like are we still cbs radio we
just sold so i'm not sure what we are
but um
we uh
you know we do services and then um
there's a couple publicists you know
what we when we get hit up it's usually
through
like a third party i don't even know if
it's third parties the right way to say
it but somebody that's you know how like
when they used to say that you know
there used to be those movies where
somebody would say hey man listen to my
they go to a record label they like
listen to my disc man it's like we don't
take unsolicited material and you never
really knew what that was it's kind of
the same thing with uh with some of the
bigger radio shows i think right but
there's different ways to to get guests
to like we go after people as well as as
opposed to you know hitting us up but
um
yeah if somebody hits us up we you know
we say no more than we say yeah right i
would imagine seriously yeah but um does
that answer that i'm sorry i'm not sure
oh no i'm i just i'm stone i probably
wasn't making sense but
another question i had was
joey and i talk a lot about how like you
promote podcasts and it's how you get it
out there
how does that work with radio because
it's more of like a local market how is
it how do you grow a radio show well
that's a good question billboards yeah
we don't uh cbs hasn't really done any
billboards in a while um but they do
campaigns you know every once in a while
where they kind of flood flood the the
things you know because radio the way we
get radio ratings has changed
you know over the last you know several
years because remember you used to have
to fill out a diary and now it's like a
little um you know i think it's a little
like pager thing that you put on your
your belt loop and as long as you're
moving it reads what you're listening to
so theoretically even if you're
listening to k earth in the car or kos
in the car
um or if you go into subway you know
like a subway sandwich shop they've got
their own radio station there too so it
you know it will register there you know
theoretically but um
you know some
they've had problems this year and i
don't really understand the problems but
the ratings have been like a little
weird um starting in january or
something so even that's a little you
know that's been a little sketchy as of
late you know
but um back to your question how do you
market or how do you grow a radio show
uh it really just takes time you know at
this point um
you know a couple things that i've
noticed i noticed that like um you know
big boy is on
uh channel five sometimes there's a lot
of cross promotion there like with k
earth with being a cbs and k rock being
cbs there's always cross promotion with
those
uh cbs shows when you're in a cluster
like i'm sorry to keep getting away from
the mic
um
when you're in a cluster you know like
knx is our news station so you know like
when prince passed away we cross promote
with knx and and things like that but um
how much has it changed in the last 10
years with it with social media and
uh well social media
radio with social media has changed
because there's um
a huge
emphasis on social media like we just
hired a social media person just for the
morning show
um
but then there's stations like outside
of indianapolis there's a station called
g1013 and they have like their home
social media network and it's actually
really cool like their morning show
and their listeners directly have a lot
of interaction you know through twitter
but also through their own platforms so
i i thought that was pretty cool um
i i love it when we get listeners
because we we have listeners call in
from arkansas
you know a lot of times we have
listeners uh you know calling from
mississippi
i i like it when they listen on the
internet or listen on their phones and
stuff like that um so that's changed
quite a bit i don't know the percentage
of our listeners that are international
but um but i like i know that when we i
was doing sports
um when i was gone that that uh that
time
i was doing play by play and there would
be people in jordan you know listening
to some of the uh the play-by-play so
that was always you know that was always
huge but social media i think is
probably the biggest tool to to promote
radio at this point much like podcasts
obviously howard stern promoted his show
in the beginning
a lot different than a show would be
getting promoted to there was no social
media right so you had to use word of
mouth consistently i remember street
teams
three teams you know i think an
interesting thing too is that like um
you know when i came on with the
hollywood hamilton show there was a
longer expectation like there was uh you
know it's going to take this amount of
time and that amount of time range from
about a year to two years and with
social media and stuff and and it's just
being a faster thing and i don't think
that a morning show would get
you know more than a couple months you
know if it was a new one coming on in a
big market you know i don't think it
would get like a two-year
run anymore it's funny when we started
this podcast we were morning radio
we would [ __ ] you know start at 6 00
a.m you know
i don't even know why we did it that way
i thought about it for one i go lee
let's just wake up early and get it over
you know but it was [ __ ] rough
because we would get blasted
we could play
[Music]
and it was hard to get guests yeah real
hard to get [ __ ] it is hard to get
guests out early in the morning yeah you
know
um
and then we switched it to the nighttime
because i thought nobody breaks
appointments you can't how busy can you
get at eight o'clock right
it's a big money gig but it's monday and
wednesday so
we decided on those little things and
we released early in the week we when we
were releasing lately in the week
our numbers wouldn't be high you know
there's so much of this was such a
grassroots type effort yeah and lee and
i saw the growth
together i mean it's kind of scary you
know it's can i can i tell a story real
quick about about uh
one time i don't know if you remember
this story or not but i took a demo that
you and i uh you brought joe rogan in
one day right do you remember this yes
he brought him in
and that show was was phenomenal it was
hilarious and it was uh it was very male
oriented and i was like this would sound
great on uh klsx which was a sister
station we had over there at cbs radio
2. and i made this demo and it was
pristine and i had a powerpoint
presentation that i was taking i was
like
joey diaz and joe rogan these guys on
the radio
this is going to be big you know this is
going to be
you know it's going to be
people are going to be into this
so i took it into the office of a man
named jack silver who's now at nbc
sports he grabs my cd throws in the
trash and he goes i need more uh talk
radio listeners not more talk radio
talkers and now you're here with your
millions of uh listens and joe rogan is
on his podcast i i tell that story all
the time because it's just uh
you know kind of indicative you know of
how timing you know works out sometimes
yeah
on the phone right now
what do you say i don't need
i need what he goes i need more talk
radio listeners not more talk radio
talkers
and he threw he threw the cd in the
trash
and uh presumably didn't dig it out and
listen to it later
but i was so proud of that demo man and
i still uh to death to this day i uh i
think that was a great demo and that was
some of the best best radio i ever heard
was when you guys came in and just
just did your thing and i sat back and
it was you know i would i would listen
to that and i'm critical of radio you
know i don't listen to a lot of podcasts
i don't listen to a lot of radio but i
would listen to that i would i would sit
tight for that you know when i do his
podcast
it's like a [ __ ] event yeah you know
like my bet i've had my agent call me
and say they talked about
you for the rogan podcast the company
meeting this morning like the numbers
you know yeah
it's i don't know what it is i don't
know what it is first off he knows how
to press my buttons
he knows
by him doing little things i'm gonna get
[ __ ] agitated and he knows me that
well i don't get agitated right away
yeah it's a slow simmer
and him and red band know how to push
that slow simmer yeah when they look at
their phones or they have talks about
phone networks and [ __ ]
that [ __ ] just drives me from insane
i've never hung out with guys that talk
about phones or shoes
[Music]
i'll never forget one time i made a
mistake
i went against my whole philosophy of
life and i got in the car with rogan and
red man
and drove to irvine to do a weekend
on friday night in traffic
and they got into a conversation about
cocaine
and i wanted to shoot them both
but they were both trying to tell me to
stop snorting coke yeah but they were
both talking like they knew about drugs
red band was talking about how right he
was a drug dealer in columbus and
creepy people coming to his dorm to tell
you something if red band was ever a
drug deal in columbus i'd rob him
that's just me i would have smacked them
let me give some shout outs here how do
you feel on the cough medicine you feel
it tonight not as much as the other
night not as much are you excited about
verizon's new unlimited pack how about i
stab you in the [ __ ] necklace
my brother dante gazzini locomotive
wart braun crystal johnson
frank white irv hughes and doc
or jack hamilton doc hamilton whatever
you know i love you [ __ ] don't
forget house of comedy tomorrow night
[ __ ] i think friday and saturday
might be thin you better get those
tickets tomorrow night
that i'm telling you
anyway who gets
no him and i i don't know what
you know it's funny i don't talk to him
much like what people would think i
talked to him when we we used to work
together i'd sit next to him on a plan
and we'd talk
and i could see that there was something
there like when we get the even on those
podcasts he knows i can be quiet for 45
minutes yeah like i'll take the beat
i'm one of those guys i play possum like
a [ __ ]
i'll let you talk all [ __ ] afternoon
but guess what i'm going to boil
eventually and i'm going to keep taking
this [ __ ] here beating
and once i get one of those beatings i
just go off i [ __ ] hate your beatings
i've hated you since i was a young man
jesus [ __ ] christ lisa yes yes sir
what are you doing over there who knows
i'm feeling good fidgeting over there
and [ __ ] like no it's fidget but no i i
i can't believe we didn't know that uh
we did that cd
i see the three of clubs i don't think
we uh i don't think he put it together i
told him did i tell you now this
afternoon you told me he told me that he
was coming on and he told me about the
uh national lampoon stuff and i i was i
was over youtube i couldn't even find
one uh but no you didn't tell me about
the three of clubs until tonight me him
what was the the kid that
helped us do with the opening that great
kid i still see him around he's around
was he was jerry doing that no no
no
i forget the kid's name that was running
and he's still around i still see him
your boy mixed it we got a little crowd
in there we giggled
whatever thank you for pushing me to do
it
yeah yeah that's right you want to do it
that's right i forgot about that yeah
yeah no no no no no no i told the truth
i [ __ ] tell people i didn't want to
do it and you talked to me and then when
you heard it you didn't like it no yeah
yeah i hate [ __ ] my voice man
you know i could be [ __ ] whitney
houston type singer and i would hate my
voice yeah one of those guys i just
don't want to see me i don't want to
hear me just play the [ __ ] thing
right you know
the only times people have contacted me
and said hey
okay this video i'm like whatever
[Music]
i'm like god damn it
why didn't i [ __ ] watch this [ __ ] i
look like why did i have that red hat on
stupid you know you gave me great advice
one time you uh i don't even know you
were trying to give advice but you said
um you're taking a blank cd into an
agent and then you asked him later how
it was he's like oh man it was great it
was great and then there was nothing on
it
[ __ ] you you're not my agent i did that
to people
i was doing that to people constantly
yeah
constantly like there was i sent one
comedy tape out and that was to mark
babbitt that was blank and he hired me
yeah i thought it was the best comedy i
see in the future
i'm [ __ ] howling at the house
and then there were agents in town that
would really agitate the [ __ ] out of me
that they would call me and i'd talk to
them and like all right i'm doing a spot
tonight 10 45 at the comedy store
and they go nah nah send us a tape
why not send your [ __ ] people you
live right here that way yeah just go to
the comedy store and see what i'm about
and this will make it easier for you
like that
and i would send them blank [ __ ]
tapes
oh that was great i don't know what was
the name of the movie uh
uh it was uh you didn't see the tape
because they ain't no tape [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] was that guy's name he's
the one that told me to put a handcuff
on
and go on stage and start talking about
being the lost what
like a handcuff around your wrist yes
like you escape from the cops yes and be
the lost and you have to travel around
the world with that
he wanted me to be the lost blues
brother
that guy is now selling [ __ ] he's the
number three guy at chipotle
he's the guy that picks up the meat and
don't make eye contact
he knows that he's giving you the guts
he's hoping to make it up to the cashier
oh my god um
what you're doing man you're still doing
what you love you're happy you're off
the [ __ ] sauce the pills whatever the
[ __ ] you want even though you'll miss
yeah i wasn't really i was on prescribed
pills i mean it was funny that i got i
had
i got mis
diagnosed diagnosed sometimes they gave
me the wrong voltage what
they gave me the wrong [ __ ] ptosis
like dosage
oh my
god there any difference damn you and
lou reed man and uh
i didn't feel good man i just didn't
feel good about myself as a human being
i mean yeah i was doing a [ __ ] gram
and a half a blow every night and then
taking the anxiety pills like
something's not right chemically
balanced but then
i took a few days off from the blow and
i kept eating those pills
and i was feeling worse the coke was
helping it
and i remember taking one of those pills
and giving it to sergio love
know surgeries you remember surgery i'm
a comedian i called them up i got
surgery i couldn't remember dude yeah i
got this pilfy it's off the charts it's
a new thing in china
let me know what you think about it it
was basically an anxiety pill yeah he
took it like two days later he's like
dog
whatever the [ __ ] that was that [ __ ] was
heavy and she's like again i never did
an anxiety pill again yeah yeah that's
why i was asking you creepy questions
about anxiety and we talk
a lot about the podcast we talk about
fears and anxiety and uh
you know today
i've been like i said i've been in hell
lately with this breathing thing yeah
and today the last thing i want to do is
go to jiu jitsu
so i go in the back i get the jump rope
i start jumping rope and guys
i can feel myself passing out yeah like
my own fear and my mind guys yeah
nothing was happening to me oh no i'm
not thinking what's happening it's like
it's like the emotion just for no reason
it over it's just there it just takes
over your [ __ ] mind guys i don't know
nothing wrong with me yeah nothing at
all and i kept jumping rope my breathing
would get heavy and i'm like self
panicking now i'm catching myself
because i kept doing it doing it doing
it doing it and i'm like i don't know
how i'm gonna make it through jiu jitsu
like when i walked in i'm like this is
not gonna be a good day yeah i drank
some [ __ ] water i kept drinking some
water i got on the line and you know
what man
20 minutes into jiu jitsu i was having a
[ __ ] blast yeah yeah sweating
everywhere dripping from my ghee in my
head i'm like this is tremendous yeah
yeah the the uh exertion helps a lot
because i i uh took up running too i
actually got a couple marathons done
no way yeah i got two of them and that's
[ __ ] that's hard but yeah i've done a
couple uh halves but um i wanted to do
the l.a marathon but today's [ __ ]
raining it's like raining constantly
here now can't train
um
but uh yeah i think the running you know
helps for sure you know just like jiu
jitsu you get a good sweat going man
that kind of that mellows a lot of
things out that makes your mind right
that first
puff of sweat that comes out of my body
when i go into panic it's the weirdest
feeling my body ever experiences yeah
it's like i do what i gotta do and all
of a sudden i'll sweat a little bit but
then there's that panic sweat where the
panic comes out and also i gotta pee
yeah
i gotta pee right away i mean right away
i gotta pee right [ __ ] now yeah it's
such a [ __ ] horrible feeling
i always kind of uh
when i would talk about it described it
like it was like a little shot glass
just filled with like crazy [ __ ] like
every fear and every anger
and every uh you know just everything
that ever made you anxious and it's just
teetering right there on a wire and you
feel it you feel it and then it tips
over and then it's just there
kind of like it just overtakes
everything
and uh yeah man when i was
excuse me
when i uh you know worked here in the
valley before i i ever started working
you know for a radio station here
you know there was a time where you know
you're just like you know i had this
little office and i'm surrounded by
nothing but file cabinets and there's no
windows and you know i can't tell you
how many times i'm just in there and
just like uh you know you're ready to
just scream you don't know what to
scream or to crawl into the table it
feels like a fire drill you know
that's you know that's real [ __ ] man
it's weird i do that sometimes in the
car if i get really frustrated yeah like
i've done that like especially coming
back from that job yeah just like just
scream if i help sometimes
right yeah
but again not since 2009 man [ __ ] hasn't
happened it was it happened like three
to seven times a day and then oh wow
yeah it was like
you know i'd always have to like excuse
myself from rooms and things like that
because you could feel it kind of coming
on but
um
yeah man i also had really bad asthma so
i was like you know i'm glad that that
life is a lot easier to deal with you
know when you're not having to [ __ ]
deal with that so i uh you know well a
lot of helpless i hope it helps out a
lot of people listen to the show that
when we discuss
situations like this couple days later
they send me emails and
they're like yeah we're happy you talked
about you know
everybody goes through weird [ __ ] oh
sure yeah this has been going on with me
for about three and a half years now
these panic attacks had jiu jitsu
i got a panic attack a little tiny one
at the wilton theater a little tiny one
i got a little tiny one at the uh
goddamn comedy jam were you performing
at the wilton yeah i did yeah i can see
that when i walked out on stage i got a
little [ __ ] whatever and now you know
what i breathe out of my nose that helps
then i got the surgery so i can actually
take those coke rocks you ever do the uh
the meditation thing you ever try that
out
i sit by myself every morning i cross my
legs yeah you know i kept my spine
straight yeah i closed my eyes and i
breathed for about seven to ten minutes
just out of my nose then i put a
mouthpiece in
and i breathe through this this is on my
workout yeah cause it blows the [ __ ] out
of me when something bothers the [ __ ]
out of me i work on it you know
i don't try to really kick it to the
side so boss rooting
he has a mouthpiece and he said that
if you do a certain workout through the
mouthpiece it'll eliminate asthma
because it makes you push oh really it's
you clip your nose you clip your nose
and you just breathe in and out in and
out
it just makes your uh
lungs no diaphragm diaphragm stronger
yeah you know so i do a little workout
in the morning so that breathing has
helped me a lot i can't
but you know where i get anxiety
you ready for this
the original room at the campus though
the original really the main room i'm
[ __ ] parishioned off yeah i come out
jumping and slinging on the [ __ ]
little room
every time i walk up those steps i get
to the top of the steps i gotta take my
jacket off
and throw in the chair and say if i have
enough time i sit then the light comes
on for the comic before me and my heart
starts racing
as he's bringing me up i just keep
breathing breathing breathing breathing
and make sure i got water breathing
breathing breathing as i'm walking up
i'm basically dying
and once i hit the stage
it just dumps
and then i do what i do but those six
minutes are a [ __ ] nightmare yeah
man and it happens with the stars
without the stars with marijuana without
marijuana like i've experimented like
well well you know i'm getting anxiety
absolutely because i'm eating 18 000
milligrams of
there's always thc chasing you when you
have 1800 milligrams of thc you know
what i'm saying
no there's nights i i won't eat for
three or four days and go down there
sure enough the original one friday at
11 30.
i woke up my heart's beating on my chest
i feel like i'm gonna [ __ ] faint yeah
you know i'm walking
minus two miles an hour and i'm gasping
for here yeah
when you guys say anxiety attack what do
you mean because i don't know
i don't know if i've had an anxiety
attack i probably just don't have
anxiety
sometimes things slow down a little bit
i think it'll seem it'll seem like a
little bit definitely doesn't slow down
or it didn't slow down for me again like
that but floating yeah
yeah again like i just had sort of
symptoms of anxiety attacks i don't
think you know it it was the sort of
panic
you know because i don't want to compare
it to that because i don't know what
other people feel when they they feel
that panic
i just know that for me a lot of things
that he's talking about the heart and
the chest but it was a racing mind so it
was like it wasn't slowed down it was
just like
you you get all this information and it
could be information that you
got five days ago that's just suddenly
just pelting your head all at once and
and you don't have a place to put it
almost
and um you know it feels like you're
gonna pass out but there's no passing
out
uh so that was you know that was one of
the things too but you know like i would
just sort of like break down in tears a
lot too you know just be sad like
you know something horrible happens but
then what's what's weird about it um i
don't know if you remember this but like
in in
like real stressful situations i could
handle [ __ ] like do you remember that uh
that car crash that happened right in
front of lampoon that time where that
chick her eyeball like exploded and
stuff i was like the first person there
and i'm all like okay you sit here i
took my shirt off bandaged your head up
call the ambulance the guys over at that
newspaper stand who are all comedians
are just like you can't do that and i'm
like did you either help
help or don't you know kind of thing um
and then i went around the corner after
all of that happened and they get her
all bandaged up getting ready to take
her out and i like puked and start
crying and oh my god stuff like that so
then that's when the attack happened but
during it
that was you know it was fine that's
when everything slowed down and
everything was like calm but
um but yeah the panic attacks were just
it's just this
you can't
i would always kind of describe it as a
um
you've got like six wheels turning and
they're all kind of turning a different
speed they're all different sides
or sizes and i've got to slow them down
and get them in sync somehow and i can't
do it you know and that's
you know that was sort of the beginning
of it and then that's what you were
always trying to do and that's what i
was always trying to do i don't think i
get full blown
anxiety attacks i get panic attacks when
i'm on the bottom
in jiu jitsu and i can't breathe
that's when i start to panic
i start to breathe through it like over
the years i learned how to breathe
through it on some things sometimes i
just tap and i have to get up and just
breathe
and then i get right back on the bottom
we start all over again um
i'm not gonna lie to you you know you
drink a soda and you eat an edible
and you got a plane and you mix caffeine
with that edible you know
i've been to the point sometimes on that
place
where i've said to myself i could see me
freaking out yeah any minute just get up
and start yelling finally
like that's the point but it's edible
pushed it's not my own mental yeah like
i never
when i get that state you're not gonna
hear a [ __ ] paper how to make you
know what i'm saying is like yellow
trauma no no no
i'm just uh
i'm scared of passing out i'm a pass out
artist yeah you know when i see blood i
pass out needles i remember that yeah
yeah yeah i'm one of those [ __ ]
your friend pass out in front of him did
he do he passed around in front of me no
no no i just remember him telling me
that and i was so shocked by that i
think that one night i went to it was a
ufc there you go it was there you go
dude
joe daddy stevenson yeah yeah b.j penn
right i'm in my house
no blow no nothing i'm sitting on the
couch minding my own business
and bj penn opens up big daddy's [ __ ]
head
and there's blood everywhere and i'm
dealing with it i'm looking away i'm
petting the cat
but all of a sudden they showed like a
towel yeah and that was it it was over
man i woke up at four in the morning my
shirt was drenched
you know my sleep apnea was in full
effect he was feeling it too like the
next day he's just like i can't believe
this is blood or not the next day but
like that tuesday i think it was
functioning me for coming yeah with
ralphie may
when i passed out on ralphie man at the
ufc
that was completely crazy yeah i was
watching the fight show when he went
into his corner same thing i saw him
wiping blood off his neck
bam i went down thank god there was a
doctor next to ralphie
but i'm one of those [ __ ] jerk-offs
i'll go down i know how to breathe now a
little better
i've been really good with the blood uh
whatever lately yeah i take blood out i
looked the other way i put an ipod on
yeah i've never i've never looked at
that i know there's people who could
shoot them themselves yeah and pull the
pump [ __ ] you yeah [ __ ] you your friend
is diabetic he doesn't even like lift
his shirt up anymore it's just like
through the shirt not just like
with the insulin yeah it's quick it
always gets me too like ah you know i i
have to look away when he does it i
would love
to do a little taste of heroin with a
needle one day what
i'm like too
but i'm not talking about the [ __ ]
they're doing in columbus and all those
dating
i'm talking about what they're doing do
a minor scoop of it just like a little
so i'm high for two hours i keep a
little bit
that type of [ __ ] i don't know if you
can place orders like that joey yeah
really if i could find somebody like
like a good nurse to come over here and
shoot me a little bit of age give me a
little [ __ ] and give me a little shot in
the ass time i swear to god joey if you
bring a nurse over here i'm driving back
to boston i wouldn't go to pick up paula
no you oh my god i'm looking forward to
get a b12 shot and i think he'll be fine
just get him about a month we're gonna
get a nurse to come in one day
and shoot this with the finest chinese
heroine that ever [ __ ] was made you
understand me well that didn't take long
at all to go from like i don't mess with
any of that [ __ ] too
this is the final frontier i'm 54 years
old i'm 28. that's right this is just a
little taste this is not a shot this is
not a hot shot this is not a ten dollar
bag this is something that we're gonna
find a nurse that's willing to do this
well for 20 bucks i could find a lot of
people doing anything for 25 bucks i
think you're just gonna find like a
a little h and the other one looking
leave kevin couch he's getting he's not
oh we'll get some chinese dude to come
and bring us opium
you know you know you do up here right
you lay back and you smoke and you
hallucinate and they turn the lights off
and they tell chinese stories and [ __ ]
what would you rather sounds like a
fascinating podcast what would you
rather do what would you rather do get
the nurse
listen late two years ago you're gonna
get you were getting again go for the
opium league i think i think i have to
draw the line at the opioids no i i've
seen peaky blinders it looks fun lee
it's fun one time i'm gonna kill nobody
don't believe nobody all these amateurs
talking [ __ ] they don't know nothing
listen until you do a little bit of
china white you don't see the real devil
all we're doing is seeing his messengers
the messenger's all i can handle lately
all this [ __ ] you've been seeing for the
last four years these are just his
messages
this ain't the original the master
disaster
it's a darkness i just love the
conversation where you somehow trick
it's like it's like how they trick those
poor women into assassinating kim
jong-un's brother in the airport
you're gonna drink this poor nurse here
we're doing b12 i got my own b12
you're like db12 i know that the un
groupon right now
you can't get a nurse from groupon
dog if they're on groupon i can talk
them into anything there's a lot of [ __ ]
you can get on groupon they're on
groupon i could talk them into anything
on groupon you get a vitamin d shot and
an adrenaline thing a vitamin b whatever
yeah for like 28 i don't know what it is
i just saw it dna i went on there for my
wife together a new yoga thing
and i got really stoned i said let me
look at yoga things and i i i didn't
know you could narrow them down
and i narrowed them down i found a yoga
studio but before i had to tolerate all
this [ __ ] for like an hour oh right and
i went i saw a [ __ ] intravenous and
d12 i also narrowed down the [ __ ]
kettlebell gyms in studio city
[ __ ] you should be ashamed of
yourself
there's thirty of them on groupon no
there's not there's there's uh
right now go right now to groupon in
front of us
right now it's the same difference they
do kettlebell class [ __ ]
go to
kettlebell classes in studio city and i
guarantee you'll get five right off the
[ __ ] top
crossfit
anything to get you out of the house
it's eighteen dollars some of them
that is the best [ __ ] deal yeah no
the kettlebell workout no no group one
oh yeah no coupon i give it i guys i use
it all the time coupon is brewing
yeah
listen i don't wanna buy the house i
just wanna lease one
right right you know there's uh
i always find it uh funny i can't
remember which show it was but there was
a concert there's like two for one
tickets and it was a good show
and they had somebody on there now the
other day they had a metallica somebody
was on that yeah and i was like whoa
yeah oh prophet's a rage it's profits of
rage two for one tickets really yeah
like when they played the uh i think
it's palladium maybe no i don't think it
was profits arranged it was somebody
bigger than profit to raise and i was in
shock oh no this is the one i saw
they got great [ __ ] deals on that
dude it's great yeah that's where i got
the [ __ ] hypnotist lady from was
groupon you know i tried to do that once
and it didn't uh take yeah it didn't
take i tried it but but it was in
fairness
it was a guy who did hypnotherapy but
then was also like a hypnotherapy
comedian kind of guy that you know
made you made you act like a you know
dip [ __ ] on stage kind of one of those
dudes is that real
i i guess it's real i mean i've seen it
that guy in boston yeah we had a guy
come into the lampoon one time and he he
he didn't get everybody but he got some
of them he got like three of them and
what do you make him do
uh
just like uh euphoric feeling of uh
orgasmic euphoric feeling and and then
she went all like you know i'm not gonna
imitate her but
um but that was the only one i remember
but i remember other people were
hypnotized i don't remember all of it
though i think i've done too many drugs
it didn't take or it did take
the first time i did it with this lady
that
uh
dr medici recommended
something happened
i gotta be honest something did [ __ ]
happen yeah
somewhere along the line i went out and
i came back i can't lie to you
did it take i don't [ __ ] know yeah
you know what i'm saying
and then uh
she gave me some key words to say
whatever i would get panic attack i
would just use the keywords and
i'm still here and then jump by the
window yeah well that's good and then
this lady here
i didn't go out but i noticed something
i noticed that
when i got there i wasn't going 100
miles an hour i walked in there like you
know
and as soon as i sat down
i got more and more like her voice
you know and she took me to somewhere i
i don't know if i passed out though yeah
hmm
what about when zombies because like i i
had my first message on a friday or
saturday we spoke about it on monday but
afterwards i just i felt like more
relaxed than i've ever felt in my life
do you do what do you guys do that for
panic or anything to help you guys
i never did no no no it was recommended
but we don't have a lot of massage
parlors and
i don't know i just
i don't know i don't want somebody
touching me when i'm having a panic
attack anyway yeah i'm laying down i'm
looking at the [ __ ] floor the other
day i went i go to the chiropractor
and laid down and i got a panic attack
yeah because i couldn't breathe
the way the thing was at that time had
me all [ __ ] up
so she's like are you okay i'm like let
not not really
i got up i looked around i breathed a
little bit and i was [ __ ] fine [ __ ]
it happens man it's how you handle those
things that's all it is i've learned i
used to
when i first experienced them i was a
kid and i think i would cry and [ __ ] but
they didn't give me dick my mom would
give me like blackberry brandy right
right right go take that and there's
there's a difference too between doing
uh
you know just being nervous about
something too that's not necessarily a
panic attack either even if it's being
really really nervous like uh you know
coming in here i was a little more
nervous than i am going to work because
it's a different environment you know
and you know you have different
listeners and are you on there i don't
care no not really it's like i'm like in
the background i'm not union so i'm not
on a microphone
um so i make little quips and [ __ ] from
time to time but uh nah mostly just a
producer and
you know button pusher and things like
that yeah but not too much
um
but uh what was i saying
what are you talking about who the [ __ ]
knows yeah i don't [ __ ] know i have
no [ __ ] idea that's good you know
it's funny probably
at least you know it's funny that you're
28 how old are you
i'm 42. you're looking good bro thanks
man looking handsome i thought you were
like 36. no thanks i was 36 when uh
we met no no no no no no no yeah when i
was younger now you're right it's like
33. it's funny like right now how old is
johnny rockley i think he's about my age
okay
you've known johnny rockman for four
years right since we shot the cd in
irvine that time and bread right yeah
in 15 years you're gonna bump into
johnny
at the comedy store or at sony
and you're gonna be so [ __ ] happy
whether you talk to him or not you know
look at somebody who survived the
[ __ ] holocaust out here well it's
weird just even just to say i have known
johnny for
probably about five years
that's weird like i think when you get
out here you just kind of put your head
down
and it's it blows my mind i've known him
for five years i've known
you for six or something like that steve
simone for five something like it's
when you really sit down and think about
how long you've known people and this
just goes for anybody i talked to today
this guy texted me for my first job ever
in l.a
he just bought a house he's really
excited and it's uh
it's just weird and like when you cut
when you come out of college you just
kind of put your head down and when you
kind of bring it up for a second i try
to tell you [ __ ] dog it moves
fast because oh it does man it was fast
[ __ ] you know if you watched uh last
week was my birthday one of my buddies
put 37 years i i i went and left the
house i'm like man how do you know
somebody
cause i mean i'm doing the math now has
it been 11 we've known each other for 11
11 years we've known each other for how
long when did you get out of here uh i
well i got out here in uh 2000
i was here already i was waiting yeah
yeah so
and i met you years later i think i met
you in 2005. yeah 2006 2005 2006. what
the [ __ ] was i promoting oh i don't know
oh no no no no i do know i do know uh
oh [ __ ] dude it was uh you were on tour
with a bunch of latin comics
piles of comedy slam
was it was it pie also i don't think it
was i think that came after no that came
after i think
oh but yeah it was it was you and um
man i'm just going to throw everybody's
scrambling in my brain right now because
i want to say joey medina but i don't
think joey medina was no
i don't know i wonder what the [ __ ] it
was
anyway i'm just happy to see you kevin
yeah man i'm glad you're happy you're in
the [ __ ] neighborhood you know what
i'm saying like that's good yeah running
into my my buddy ran into you at
7-eleven too he said yeah somebody
it's weird man i run into a lava just
now i went over to the wheat stone i
bumped into kevin's buddy yeah so i got
kevin's number kevin from uh the guy
that built the studio oh yeah so i got
his number you know he
this is a small community yeah you know
this is small over here this is just
like i like it yeah i don't want to live
anywhere else in california i love these
these five or six little blocks here
yeah i love it are you in this block
around here i mean i don't want to give
away your ass yeah close to a little
canyon okay but i'm in that little nice
white nest in there yeah
it's just a white nest of nice people i
mean i like i lived in silver lake for
so long like i lived in silver lake from
like 2000 until uh whatever 2009 or
something like that and then everybody
always bad talks the valley but i'm not
from here so i don't really have a frame
of reference but then i get to the
valley and i'm like this is like quiet
and my car's not getting stolen i love
it man i'm down i'm down for sure let me
tell you how white my name is
this morning the babies talking to my
wife and my son you know i was already
stoned
i ate breakfast i wrote i
i did a video i tweeted
i i look at them and i go you know what
i'm going to start the call my wife
drives her but i go i take the right mom
we take my wife's car
i go out there and start my wife's car i
don't want to listen to [ __ ] music
it's beautiful out this morning yeah you
know there's nothing like a nice dose of
vitamin d [ __ ]
when that sun's fresh yeah the air is
fresh i went out there just sat on every
morning i get out here i've run by this
place before like i get out and run on
the weekends at like six in the morning
five in the morning because that's you
know that's when i'm up anyway so i know
exactly what you're talking about you
know i was out there just getting there
man yeah
i didn't give a [ __ ] how long they took
i was stoned the sun was beating on my
face just that situation with that
warmth yeah i've always been a fan of
that [ __ ] warmth even when i lived in
jersey it was cold
just that that sun you know
first person who walks by me is a guy
with a dog
hey how you doing good morning
beautiful dog thank you
black chick walked by me with a [ __ ]
chihuahua good morning i said good
morning to her she looked me straight in
the face said good morning nice day
today thank god it's not raining some
stupid [ __ ] have a great day
some [ __ ] white dude old like 90.
about 10 minutes like i'm 10 minutes
maybe like four minutes later he walks
by he just waves
okay okay because there's a park by my
house so they go to the park and walk
around the park yeah so i'm sitting
there and i look at this i look down the
corner and there's this woman she's got
to be maybe 44.
i know she's married uh
she's got expensive clothes on you know
i'm saying like she's got a hoodie and
the whole [ __ ] d right
and she's walking towards me she spots
me
and she crosses the street
so i just want to see what the situation
is yeah yeah so she gets by my house
saying good morning
guys not even a [ __ ] friendly [ __ ]
you yeah and right after her another
chick that thought she was [ __ ] kim
kardashian
i was walking she's on my side of the
street she's 10 yards from me she
crosses the street like i'm gonna tackle
her
[ __ ] garage or something right
nothing bothers me more than that and i
go good morning that [ __ ] hack didn't
say nothing and you know what the weird
thing is you'll be at like a
house party or something in the area
they'll they'll find out what you do and
then they'll want to talk to you
because they they just didn't want to
talk to you because again i don't know
maybe because you're a big guy i don't
know i don't want to talk to them i i
know you won't now [ __ ] want to talk
to them
i wouldn't want to go to those parties
with type those type of people last time
i went to i got talked into going to an
oscar park
and i talked to my wife i go honey we
got to do something time to time
somebody invited us we gotta go like
[ __ ] civilians
we were there five minutes
my wife looked and she's like we gotta
go
and it was a casting director well i had
never seen anything like this it was
those type of people yeah would walk by
me and cross the street or yeah yeah
he's a scary guy from new jersey oh my
god i hate new jersey people right so i
don't even give him the [ __ ]
satisfaction you know i'm saying [ __ ]
that
at least i am scared to ask yes sir what
is on the agenda for the weekend this
weekend well i'm gonna go to uh
the casino tomorrow i think all right
either tomorrow or friday
um i've been playing paula got me this
like
full set like actual legit set so we've
been playing at home non-stop
um
and then i don't know we don't have any
no pugs nothing we're having a pug
wheeling plan this weekend no no crepe
classes
you never made another crepe you know
and she and i got her crepe maker i was
like she's gonna make another crepe
maker either yeah we'll [ __ ] eat
grapes i would i would love christmas
the [ __ ] out of here
that's it that's all you're doing this
week yeah i don't think we have any
full-on legit plans we'll do something
how about you there my brother from a
different mother dude this is my weekend
of responsibility to the uh taxes done
oh yeah yeah yeah
doing all that doing all that i think
you're picking up the black kid
like the big brother program no no no
pick it up a little cute little black
kid taking them to [ __ ] we're gonna go
play some frisbee in the park go fight
some dogs we gotta join the big brother
program that's not a bad idea i've been
a big brother i've done big brothers
before my brother my real brother has
actually been in big brothers for a long
time and did it for a while you still in
there i don't think he does it anymore i
think he moved and i think his little
brother got big so he doesn't uh so
reason i asked you what's your twitter
handle
oh yeah so my twitter handle let me uh
because i want there was a story that
went with this so i went from lampoon
where i'm doing joey interviewing joey
diaz all the time
and talking about very adult things to
uh doing sports which involved a lot of
high school games some around high
school kids so i pretty much douched
everything out uh i would love to get
this started again it's at kevin couch
but the kevin is with the c and the k
is uh spelling couch so it's
kevin c-e-v-i-n couch k-o-u-c-h
okay and is that you spell your name or
is that just how you're gonna that's how
i had to spell it on twitter okay that's
kevin couch the traditional way all
right yes but just in the twitter
reverse it gotcha yeah you just gotta
gotta reverse that a little bit i don't
really use twitter that much though to
be honest with you don't you find like
social media uh i know you guys are
getting out of here but like i i don't
like getting on facebook and [ __ ]
anymore i don't care about people's
opinions like right now i'm like
i've never read so many books in such a
short time in my life as right now
because i just i don't like watching tv
facebook has gotten very weird after the
election
yeah
twitter is still okay i have a good time
on twitter yeah i still see some [ __ ]
pictures and [ __ ] like that on twitter
from time to time
it's beneficial that girls on twitter
the one that caught into the podcast
that lit guys [ __ ] and [ __ ] she's
naked on twitter no it's tremendous look
isn't she uh ma i don't know what the
proper word for it is doesn't she isn't
she a prostitute well it's a word is not
a prostitute she works at the chicken
farm
prostitute is a very
avant-garde service provider
i'm sorry come on and but she put
pictures up i mean [ __ ] ted's tattoo
over the [ __ ] and there's somebody else
on my twitter feed
some other crazy chick look at this
i know taylor vixen's back
but she has to show the titties it's the
other one
there's another crazy one
the cuban girl dropped out the lesbian
that would always put pictures of a
[ __ ] and [ __ ] i think twitter finally
called the wreck and said you gotta stop
because i've heard from different porn
people like there's a girl i spoke to
one night that said
twitter
if she would put a picture of herself
with a tit up within 10 minutes the
picture would be down oh really but her
best friends show [ __ ]
dicks and [ __ ] the whole [ __ ]
thing on twitter don't give a [ __ ]
twitter was not for christians you don't
say it
if you're not on twitter because you
don't eat ass your father
lisad has been eating blue apron for
about four or five months now he's got
his dad doing it you know what i got a
couple other friends that have done it
people who are on the go
people who want to eat healthy people
want to learn how to cook
people who want to
save money you know people who don't
want a lot of people around save time
that's what blue apron is about blue
apron's mission is to make incredible
home cooking accessible
to everyone you understand me
you got
dishes that would kill you i mean
they're delicious how good they are lee
brought over that chicken with the thing
that day you brought over a little piece
to the house it was [ __ ]
tremendous i can't believe this now
listen not all ingredients are created
equal
fresh high quality ingredients make a
real difference so it's important to
know where your food comes from
all right lee loves it he loves the
meals him and his wife get together and
they turn into date night and between
you and i lee is learning how to cook
i'm watching them call me up at night
and go you know what no i'm learning how
to do this i'm learning how to do that i
mean you're not going to be a [ __ ]
chef but
at least you're learning how to cook i
cooked on valentine's day
i didn't have a blue apron meal but i
would in years i would have never done
that and i cooked i i found a recipe
online and i took the skills that i've
done i've done some of these things in
blue apron and it's uh it's great we had
which [ __ ] that if you loved her it
would be blue apron that's right dog for
less than ten dollars per meal blue
apron delivers seasonal recipes along
with proportioned
pre-portioned ingredients to make
delicious home-cooked meals choose from
a variety of new recipes each week or
that bracelen's culinary team surprise
you recipes are not repeated within a
year so you'll never get bored customize
your recipes each week based on your
preference blue apron has several
delivery options so you can choose what
fits your needs and there's no weekly
commitment so you don't get only get
deliveries when you want them each meal
comes with a step-by-step
easy to follow recipe card
pre-portioned ingredients that can be
prepared in 40 minutes or less you get
home at six by 6 45 you're sitting there
like a soldier blue apron's freshness is
guaranteed
and they promise that every ingredient
in your delivery arrives ready to cook
or they'll make it right all right this
week's menu let me let me turn you on to
this week's menu let's say you get the
two people menu you got smoky pork
burgers and blackened chicken and rice
let's say you get the family thing you
got sicilian style muccatini and you got
cod and tomato stew who's better than
you do me a favor
go to boyfriend.com right now slash joey
all right this is what we're gonna do
for you you're gonna love how it feels
and taste and create incredible
home-cooked meals with blue apron so do
not wait you understand me what we're
going to do is
go to boyfriend.com right now joey
check out this week's menu and get your
first free meals free okay with free
shipping by going to blue apron.com
slash joey you'll love how it feels and
taste and to create incredible
home-cooked meals that's blueapron.com
joey blue apron a better way to cook all
right i love this stuff i think you're
gonna love it too now
after you eat you want to catch a little
siesta
okay
everybody wants to take a little
napping that's why uncle joey comes in
again
because nobody sleeps right
but with a helix sleep mattress
you're going to sleep like a doctor
every night you know why because you're
unique you don't walk like everyone you
don't talk like everyone you don't sleep
like everyone so why is your matches one
size fits all you might as well go to
north hollywood get a mattress and go
home and die
because custom mattresses will cost you
five to ten thousand bucks until today
until uncle joey introduces you to helix
sleep where you can buy a mattress
online customized for you for hundreds
of dollars instead of thousands who's
better than you go to helixleep.com
answer a few simple questions based on
four key preferences and the result will
be a custom sleep profile used to build
you the most comfortable mattress you'll
ever sleep on your mattress will arrive
at your door in about a week and
shipping is a hundred percent free and
for couples healers customizes each side
of the mattress helix customers report a
30 improvement in overall sleep quality
you got 100 nights to try it out if you
don't like it they'll pick it up for
free and give you a hundred percent
refund that's why everyone from g2
magazine to four was all talking about
helix sleep do me a favor all right
everybody wants to be comfortable go to
helixsleep.com right now slash joey and
get fifty dollars off your order that's
right that's helixsleep.com
joey fifty dollars off your order
healingsleep.com
joey i also wanna listen
this shroom tech sport is tremendous if
you just go to on it and get the shroom
tech support and the hemp protein you're
going to love me for the rest of your
life go to honda.com right now and press
in church bam
c-h-u-r-c-h and get 10 off your first
order delivered to your house i want to
thank honett i want to thank helix sleep
and i want to thank my people blue apron
feeding people for 10 or less all right
i'll see you guys monday morning stay
black i love you guys i want to thank my
main man kevin couch thank you joey
bodyguard and trusted goombah
lee syed the flying jew the pride of
israel
and i'm your host joey diaz see you this
weekend at [ __ ] house economy
in minneapolis stay black
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]